there's very great Segway our buddy
Vinnie here went to jail for six months
yeah we talked about this with Maynard
from Tool yeah we've talked about it
with with a number of people and um it
started off with Knoxville right that
started yeah
uh when we weren't even recorded we were
just hanging out I just thought it would
be really funny to start talking about
prison Pockets right and now I'm just
known as prison pocket Vinnie yeah so
you went to jail for six months badly
addicted to heroin yeah and brought when
you so you surrendered yourself yeah I
surrendered where where did you
surrender yourself it's a court
um was it at like a a court yeah like an
actual Courthouse would you get caught
for
um that charge was for a larceny larceny
is anything over 1500 no anything under
not larceny six under anything under
fifteen hundred dollars okay yeah and um
Okay so
I know that when I had my second drunk
driving arrest I showed up to the
arraignment was it the arraignment like
uh and um
and I asked like I want to plead guilty
and just can I turn myself in now like
uh and I don't want to go all the way
home and then come all the way back and
let's get it all done and you want to
get over with yeah yeah did you do that
no we were trying to fight it at this
one I had a a really shitty lawyer
um but when you were living in a porta
potty you had a shitty lawyer yeah
it was the it was the advertisement on
the porta potty he's like maybe I can
call this guy yeah no this was actually
before the porta potty like a pretty
good while before it but um
yeah I I went to court a few times just
trying to like get my sentence lowered
you know I just keep fighting it and
eventually they offered what they gave
me what does that even look like does
that mean that you had a trial
um no it was more of like okay we go in
I talk to my lawyer he goes okay this is
what they're gonna offer you I said it
wasn't a court date no it wasn't a court
date and then I go in he says okay the
judge is offering you this much I either
accept or decline and who is he offering
you the first one was like over a year
and I was like no [__] that second one
was like nine months no [__] that and
then like the cap was like six months
um and the charge again was for Percocet
pills no this one was for larceny six
then I got this jail time because I've
had a couple felons felonies before that
what's larceny six me Larson E6 is just
stealing stuff
under uh fifteen hundred dollars like
that's the value of under fifteen
hundred dollars right so so it was like
it's kind of like white like a white lie
it's like white stealing uh so what what
I would do oh God uh so what I would do
is I would like go into
um
like grocery stores with like a shopping
cart and I would take
like uh the 12 cases of Red Bull and
Monster and then I would just take them
to my local Bodega and sell them for a
dollar piece
to the bodega man yeah to the boat
that's pretty
that's like good guy theft yeah yeah
it's just junky theft like when I was
homeless
it's been like Robin of larceny
I can uh like the beginning of 1994 my
Emma was uh
to um I would do like a backflip or just
something you know like something for
like you know 25 cents because I'd come
up with 25 cents maybe I'd even just beg
for 25 cents and then like I'd be able
to buy like a loaf of bread for like 50
cents but when I went in to go buy the
loaf of bread like I would tuck a pack
of hot dogs into like my my coat yeah
and then so that buying the loaf of
bread was more of an exercise and like
making sure that nobody appeared to be
on to me so I knewers I made a
legitimate purchase yeah like you know
stole the hot dogs bought the bread and
then I would take that all over to the
7-Eleven and use their microwave to cook
the hot dogs oh okay yeah yeah and use
all their condiments to load up the the
hot dogs you guys never buy beer and
like tuck your pant leg into your shoe
and just stick 40s down your leg it
never did that
all right
no okay so minor theft you go and now
you got to go to jail for six months
yeah and you're when do you turn
yourself into jail when did I well I
mean I'm just saying like you uh you
read your plea they they so they gave me
like a couple days and I had to come
back to the courthouse to turn myself in
and then I put me in cuffs and put me in
the back of the Paddy Wagon
okay yeah and uh and put you in the back
of the Paddy Wagon at that point are you
already key student okay so you knew
what the plea deal was gonna be yeah and
you were like all right I know I'm going
to the courthouse I know I'm gonna
accept six months I know I'm gonna be
dub sick so I'm putting a bunch of stuff
up you headed up your butt in the
courthouse yeah
yeah and so you had uh you said 10
bundles no 10 Xanax bars 10 Xanax bars
yeah two bundles so there's ten packs of
heroin per bundle yeah but remember the
packs of dope are tiny it's like it's
like it's one fix yeah no no no one
bundle can get me like through a few
days if I run if I if I ration it like
that if I'm if I'm home I'm not doing
that I'm not rationing like that's like
ordering a Happy Meal and
savory fries yeah yeah
yeah who does that
okay yeah okay so so one bundle can get
you through three days if you're deaf if
yeah if I'm really and you've had 20
bundles no I had 20 bags two bundles
each bundle has ten bags yeah
okay so each bundle has so one bag yeah
is one fix yeah
so yeah two bags so you can get through
one a week yeah if you're a desperate
yeah yeah yeah it lasted me a little
over a week
so what did you do after the okay we'll
get to that later yeah so you got
uh 20 bags two bundles yes and you've
got uh two grams of tobacco yeah two
packs of Rolling Papers yeah
um 10 Xanax bars yes and a hypodermic
needle yeah all wrapped around with
Saran Wrap yes and then a condom over
the whole thing double wrapped with
condoms double wrapped with condoms yeah
and the size of that lengthwise about
six inches maybe
uh no maybe five four so it's like a
like a cigar like a yeah standard-ish
for sure good and thick sure yeah yeah
and right up the old poop shoot yeah and
when I did it the first time when I did
the first time I didn't give a f I
didn't care what would happen to me
because like right you know there's so
many things that can go wrong when you
did it the first time I mean when you're
putting needles up your butt
yeah what could possibly be ready
I didn't care you know
um
because yeah because there's a [__]
needle in my keister so right so it's
keister a scientific term no I don't
think
you go to the court with this in there
yeah then then you agree to the plea
deal yeah they handcuff you in the
courtroom yeah in The Paddy Wagon yeah
now they're going to take you over to
the the city jail yeah and for to be
processed into jail and then presumably
you'll be processed into there and then
transported over to more of a County
Jail yeah
and um
for
uh
for you to feel like you were settled in
there like not under the radar and ready
to remove the package from your keister
took a little over 24 hours a little
over 24 hours yeah because it takes a
while for for you to get settled in you
know um like you you got to go through
so many things you got to see it like uh
go through so many like checkbox shots
yeah right exactly and uh and they ask
you to uh lift up your ball sack and
costs yeah they did but they didn't like
Peak super hard I mean they would have
to lift some folds yeah
for sure right yeah
um so but like and all that was also
terrifying you know I'm like oh [__]
they're gonna find all this up me right
now and that's another charge
major felony and by the way as well as
this story unfolds keep in mind we
haven't even gotten to the prostitute
action that we had this week yeah it's
been a heavy week it's been a really
really heavy week yeah and um thank God
we've got so much to talk about because
uh it means a lot to me when we do a
podcast without a guest yeah but back to
your uh 24 hours in yeah where are you
in one of these huge kind of gymnasts
I'm in a dorm I'm in a dorm and I'm on
top bunk which sounds like the museum
and it's got it's filled with bunks
Maybe
maybe 30 bucks maybe more than that 40
bucks detoxing at this point
um I'm starting to feel sick yeah um and
I'm just like oh my God I need to get
this out of me I need to get loaded
somehow and um but 24 hours later you
know I'm like okay I think I feel safe
enough where I could just like go to the
toilet and try to get this thing out of
me and that's what I did and
and it was the best thing that's because
I knew like I was going to be so sick
aren't there cameras in the toilets or
can't they see what's going on nah
there's cameras like not you're not in
the toilets there's cameras on
everything you could possibly do maybe
accept a ticket yeah yeah except the
dump taking a dump and taking a shower
oh that's why so much violence goes down
in the shower huh yeah
um that's why they say don't drop the
soap and it's worth mentioning too that
the type of heroine that you had in your
keister was not the kind that you have
to cook in a spoon I think I think the
Layman pictures like oh heroin in order
to shoot up here when you have to cook
it in a spoon yeah that's if you're
using black tar heroin yeah when you had
that powdered China White exactly so all
you have to do with the powdered China
White is simply mix it well just yeah
mix it with water preferably purified
water but you didn't care I would have
mixed it with Port-A-Potty water
the blue liquid
I mean I've used some crazy [__] to mix
my mix my stuff up before right yeah so
uh I can see you go to the the toilet
yeah poop it out this is the better than
any Christmas morning you've ever for
sure yeah I'm on top of the world right
um where do you begin to unwrap the
package every right there right in the
toilet yeah right in the toilet I don't
even I don't even wait till like I get
right right there right you get right
with God right yeah
yeah you become one with the universe
yeah and uh and so are other people
waiting to use the toilet or I don't
think so no is this like the middle of
the night it was middle of the night
yeah okay so you get right you're so
happy you're able to flush down the um
all the condoms everything you don't
need yeah everything that remains stinks
pretty bad
yeah yeah for sure and then I would just
like to go back to my bunk you know I I
don't feel safe enough safe enough
keeping it in my pockets so like I'll
like keep it in my butt cheeks right you
know for most of the time yeah and then
like I'll go to my bunk because I stash
it in your sheets on your back because
they check your sheets and stuff like
randomly you don't know when it's gonna
happen they might not at all you know
but like
that again that's another charge so you
don't wanna
I'm loving this story how long are you
in the gymnasium type setup with all the
bunk beds before you get into it no I
was in there the whole time Oh I thought
you said you had a selling no it was uh
yeah my bunky so wait you you [__] it
out do you rig up right there right
there you pop a Xanax right there so you
that's and then you smoke a cigarette uh
no I didn't smoke at the time because I
was afraid I didn't draw attention and
then they'd come in yeah you smoke
outside so that was your deal you rigged
up popped the Xanax and then you walked
back like and then yeah
he's just looking did you rig up and
then Papa's Xanax or Papa Xanax first
you gotta wait for the Xanax to come oh
no I popped the Xanax in the rig but I'm
not waiting for the Xanax to call and I
pop it sure of course yeah yeah but
you're not you're not gonna shoot up and
then pop Xanax you can pop Xanax and
then shoot yeah yeah can you imagine
this guy walking back to the [__] bug
you look at the cameras and you're just
like I'm just [__]
I mean we've got to be so obvious dude I
like to I like to think that I hit it
pretty well you had the same bunk bed
for the whole six months the whole six
months you're in the same room yeah the
top bunk and like when I was out of all
the drugs and I got dope sick I was on
the top bunk and it was the worst worst
feeling I've ever had in my life I was
[__] my pants like it was
um
you didn't go without drugs the whole
time right well it's like okay I I'm
done with mine it's not the easiest
finding more in jail you know it's like
I don't like this so like I try to keep
to myself and only stick with a few
people but me I I probably got loaded on
other people's [__] maybe
five times the whole time I was there
had you pay for it just store stuff
with stores you know you get like like
commissary yeah commissary like Cookie
Balls or coffee balls or I guess honey
buns
that's commissary stuff which requires
you to have money on your book for sure
did were people putting money on your
books um my mom put a little bit of
money on my books but that was about it
okay yeah she was like over my [__] and
like
she's weird yeah I was like why would
you like that yeah can you believe it
so what about uh would you ever like
forego a meal to be able to trade your
uh like a hot meal yeah like a
um no yeah that's not your ammo no yeah
what about like prison debt were you
worried about going in the debt no no
you ever get any fights in prison nope
everybody thought I was Puerto Rican in
prison so it's like I learned more
Spanish in there than I did in school
wow okay all right well so you were sick
most of the time yeah for a while and um
at no point did you think man this is a
like a real gift that I'm I'm detoxing
in jail
um now I could just stay sober no I
didn't think of it as like oh it's a
real gift like how we were talking with
bam that it might work like that it was
more of like oh my God this is a
miserable existence I'm never gonna go
back to that [__] ever again
this is a miserable existence I'm never
gonna go without heroin again
instead of vapors they're using flavored
Air instead of electronics we're all
natural over here go to try fume.com
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com slash Stevo and use the
promo code Stevo at checkout you will
not only get a great deal but you'll get
an additional 10 off your order because
you are a listener of the Wild Ride
podcast
yeah dude